en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
selección r y la selección acá aquí
tenemos un camaleón hembra que acaba de
poner dos huevos y aquí tenemos una rana
que acaba de poner miles de huevos una
de éstas es selección k.o estratega kan
y otra es selección r o estratega r si
ustedes ya saben cuál es cuál
probablemente no necesiten ver el resto
de este vídeo pero para los que no vamos
a ver cada tipo de selección básicamente
tenemos que hablar de crecimiento
poblacional en cualquier población que
tenga una erre positiva r significa tasa
de crecimiento vamos a tener un
crecimiento cuya gráfica luce así en
donde primero tenemos un crecimiento
exponencial y eventualmente cuando se
acabe el alimento o el espacio
comenzarán a competir por los recursos y
se llegará a lo que llamamos crecimiento
logístico esta parte de la gráfica que
tiene forma de j
corresponde al crecimiento exponencial
mientras que la que tiene forma sin idea
se corresponde al crecimiento logístico
n va a ser el número de individuos en la
población si ponemos n de este lado y
ponemos tiempo en el eje x conforme pasa
el tiempo va a aumentar el número de
individuos aquí tendremos un valor
pequeño de n aquí tendremos un valor un
poco mayor de n y hasta aquí tendremos
un valor muy grande de n es importante
recordar que n es el número de
individuos de la población r es la tasa
de crecimiento generalmente será
positivo calculamos la tasa de
crecimiento tomando el número de
individuos que nacen y restándole el
número de individuos que mueren el
resultado lo dividimos entre el número
original de individuos si este valor es
positivo tendremos una gráfica como ésta
aunque no siempre será tan pronunciada a
veces crecerá gradualmente con el tiempo
pero otras veces puede crecer muy
rápidamente dependiendo del valor de r
la última letra es k y es la capacidad
de carga
esta es la máxima cantidad de individuos
de una población que un área determinada
puede soportar por eso se le llama
capacidad de carga y es este límite de
acá al cual llegará la población
eventualmente esto es una fórmula
matemática un modelo pero en el mundo
real se regresaron los lobos al parque
de yellowstone por lo que hubo mucho
alimento y poca competencia entonces su
tasa de crecimiento aumentaba hasta
cierto punto y luego disminuía después
aumentaba y luego disminuía de nuevo
cada vez que alcanzaba la capacidad de
carga que es el máximo número de lobos
que puedes tener en el parque de
yellowstone la gráfica no será tan suave
como ésta pero sin duda tendrá un valor
de r el valor de n va a aumentar hasta
que alcance el valor de k por eso es
importante saber qué significa la r la n
y la k
otra cosa importante es comprender la
manera en la que la vida existe esta es
la historia de la vida y de la muerte y
de cómo van a variar solamente tendremos
tres tipos
diferentes ustedes tienen la curva de
supervivencia tipo 1 lo que significa
que si piensan en todas las personas que
nacieron en el mismo lugar el mismo día
la mayoría van a sobrevivir al nacer
aunque algunos pocos mueran al principio
la gran mayoría va a sobrevivir llegarán
a la adolescencia la edad adulta la
madurez y eventualmente caerán y todos
morirán en los últimos 10 15 o 20 años
esto es porque pertenecemos al tipo 1
somos humanos e invertimos mucho tiempo
y energía en el cuidado parental de
nuestra descendencia ahora veamos a las
ranas ellas tienen la curva de
supervivencia tipo 3 en el primer día
tendremos miles de renacuajos la mayoría
de ellas morirán pero algunas de ellas
sobrevivirán después se equilibrarán y
eventualmente todas morirán también
tenemos algo intermedio llamado tipo 2
un ejemplo son las aves cantoras ellas
van a morir con una tasa lineal durante
todo su ciclo de vida el petirrojo es un
ejemplo en promedio el petirrojo vive un
año
viven sólo unos meses y otros viven
hasta tres años pero en promedio su
curva va a caer linealmente hasta que
todos mueren toda la cohorte o conjunto
de aves que nacieron en el mismo día
recuerden que nuestros ambientes son
diferentes algunas poblaciones viven en
ambientes relativamente estables como un
desierto y a veces en ambientes no tan
estables como la selva tropical o el
arrecife de coral en especial justo
ahora en donde estos están cambiando
radicalmente casi todos los días veamos
con más detalle cómo son las especies de
selección r o estratega ser estas
especies son aquellas que basan su vida
en r y recuerden que r es la tasa de
crecimiento así que estas son especies
que quieren crecer rápidamente y
explotar su nicho tan rápido como puedan
normalmente estos organismos viven en
ambientes inestables tienen alta
fecundidad y la fecundidad significa que
pueden tener muchos bebés en poco tiempo
en general son organismos pequeños que
no viven mucho tiempo
descendencia se dispersa hasta el fin de
la tierra un ejemplo sería el diente de
león que aparece a inicios de la
primavera se reproduce rápidamente y si
alguna vez han visto un diente de león
con sus semillas sabrán que éstas se
dispersan o vuelan por doquier requieren
muy poco cuidado parental las bacterias
los insectos las diatomeas que son algas
microscópicas unicelulares los calamares
bebés cuyos huevos son depositados por
la hembra y después el macho espases su
esperma sobre ellos sobre ellos ambos
padres se van después de esto y los
dejan eventualmente nacen los calamares
la mayoría se vuelven alimento para los
peces pero algunos de ellos terminan
sobreviviendo estas son las especies de
selección ere o estratega ere las que
ponen su vida en la tasa de crecimiento
cuáles son las especies de selección cal
o estratega que son las especies que
ponen sus vidas alrededor de la
capacidad de carga
y apuestan a la carrera larga van por el
crecimiento exponencial y luego por el
crecimiento logístico quieren vivir
mucho tiempo por lo general viven en un
medio ambiente más estable tienen un
tamaño corporal grande y tienen mayor
esperanza de vida tienen mucho cuidado
parental y nosotros como humanos somos
una especie de selección o estratega acá
si vemos a las plantas y comparamos a
este árbol con el diente de león algunos
árboles viven cientos o incluso miles de
años las ballenas son otro ejemplo de
especies de selección k o estratega que
aunque no siempre tienen que ser grandes
por ejemplo vean el gaviotín del ártico
que vive décadas y tienen mucho cuidado
parental por lo que son estrategas
tengan en cuenta que en la vida no
necesariamente tiene que ser todo o una
cosa u otra hay algunas especies que
muestran continuidad entre estas dos
estrategias si ustedes ven a una tortuga
de mar se darán cuenta que es grande
vive mucho tiempo por lo que quizás sea
un estratega acá
pero si recuerdan cómo nacen ellas ponen
muchos huevos los ponen en un hueco en
la arena los entierran y se alejan
cuando estas tortugas bebés salgan de
sus huevos estarán por su cuenta lo que
es más parecido a la estratega r así que
en un mismo ciclo de vida se puede ser
estratega de ica
incluso por el género no aplica mucho en
los humanos pero por ejemplo en algunos
animales los machos tienden a
comportarse más como las especies de
estrategia r producen tanto como pueden
esparcen su esperma lo más posible
mientras que las hembras tienden a ser
más estrategas acá invirtiendo mucho en
sus descendientes durante más tiempo
regresemos a la primera diapositiva que
vimos el camaleón es estrategia r o
estratega k bueno está invirtiendo en
solamente dos huevos por lo que cuidará
más tiempo a sus crías por lo que es el
estratega k mientras que la rana es
estratega r
espero que esto les haya sido útil